he's Jordy Nelson he once played for the
Packers and retired as a member of the
Oakland Raiders won a Super Bowl and he
joins us now in the program Geordi how's
morale it's good everything's great
it's good to be to have that chapter
done and looking forward to the next was
there any chance you could have gone
back to the Patriots Packers no they
didn't show any interest at all after
last year after being released by
Oakland and so I don't think that door
was ever opened again so but I have
talked to Marc Murphy and he's opened up
the door to come back and do the one-day
deals so we're still working on a time
to get that done and that way I can sign
a contract and retire a packer and you
know and where we started
is it health-related like why are you
retiring it's not advice was great and I
guess so I guess it took me
health-related because I want to leave
the game in that way I don't want to
play as long as I can until my body is
beat up and I'm forced out another thing
was I didn't really feel like moving my
family again they haven't even been out
here in California for a year and so
that was part of it and you know after
playing 11 years and then five in
college and then four nights or two of
those 27 years of footballing I think
I've had a good time and enjoyed it and
kind of want to go you know out playing
good I don't want to slowly just get you
know less and less time every year and
then just kind of fall out of league so
am I going out on top like winning a
Super Bowl but also going out when I
wanted to and my wife tries so extremely
you know proud of what we accomplished
and what we've done on and off the field
and you know we just felt like we looked
at it all different angles probably
talked about it for a couple weeks
trying to decide what to do and every
time I came down to just move back to
Kansas and get the kids back in their
school it's opf the rest of their life
and get back on the farm
who tried to talk you into continuing to
play no one tried to convince me
senior to play the Seahawks showed great
interest once I got released and I have
a lot of respect for John Schneider and
that organization they reached out last
year to and I got released by Green Bay
so I went up there and had a visit with
them but like I said Oakland tried to
get me to come back at a different deal
but like I said when I came down to it
we just decided not to move our family
again and go home and every done and be
happy with it so we're not like we're
not second-guessing anything we did I
said we left I talked about it every day
for two weeks you know from different
angles trying to convince ourselves to
retire trying to convince herself to
play trying to convince herself that
let's go move again but every time we
did it always came back to just be done
I mean if you even told me 11 years ago
when I got drafted that I have 11 your
career when it's super cool
and everything that I accomplished I
think I would take it and run off into
the sunset and and be happy and that's
what's gonna happen what's tougher
farming or football man farming is
longer days I think it'd be harder for
someone to adjust to farming and doing
that day in and day out you know
year-round compared to I think you can
get used to playing football I mean if
you're someone that's led I think it's
farming is a toll on the body it's a
different it's just different when I go
back in the summers even now and
obviously we'll be there year-round just
constantly being on your feet being
constantly working from 7:00 o'clock in
the morning till during summertime at
7:00 or 8:00 9:00 o'clock at night that
you're still out doing stuff because you
don't pay attention what time it is if
the Sun's up you're still kind of going
in so I can get you know another thing
accomplished so when you're putting in
those hours and constantly constantly
moving it it wears on you and that's why
I enjoyed doing it during the summer
because it made training camp so long
days kind of camp seemed easy it was
easy to go sit in meetings all day it
was easy
go practice for a couple hours and then
you know so the body was used to being
up all day
how did Aaron Rodgers do
the form he struggled in Kansas get
allergies so you might need a better run
at it
we've had some good stories of people
coming back we had another one they come
back for my benefit cost tournament that
we put on in June and so you're gonna
see a little bit taste of the farm and
then sigh golf but he was sneezing the
whole time ranked office around in
Kansas Bombo quality and he went home
after the golf tournament take a quick
nap woke up four hours later and said I
could come get him I said well the
events over with buddy I'm coming home
for the different different life when
you got to be a 12 hours a day
aside from winning that Super Bowl aside
from winning that Super Bowl what's your
favorite individual moment that you had
oh man I don't know if I can name one
moment I think when I came back from my
ACL and that whole year following it
ended up wouldn't come back last year
and it wasn't even necessarily obviously
performing well and being successful in
the field was huge but being able to
practice for 16 straight weeks and not
miss a day of practice and I had to take
a day off because of my knee knowing the
process it took to get back from that
and you know the build-up to the season
and everything and to be able to do that
was a huge accomplishment accomplishment
for me and I take a lot of pride right
and I think a lot of the athletic
trainers that I hadn't been baked they
did a great job of not only physically
preparing me but mentally keeping my
mind fresh keeping my mind into it the
thing a lot of guys struggle with big
surgeries like that is they get in a low
like it I want to say depress so just
get down and can't can't stay up and I
think your mind is a very powerful
muscle that can control a lot of things
and if you stay up and enjoy the process
I try to enjoy the process of coming
back some nacl as much as possible and
then how to success
it was I was very proud of and always
helped me understand this on December 28
Jon Gruden says that yeah you're coming
back and the Raiders gave you 3.6
million dollar bonus and then they cut
you March 14 so what what happened from
December 28 to march 14th that you were
no longer wanted in Oakland I don't know
they just gave me a very nice retirement
pretty yes I guess yeah I don't know
it's it's a crazy business as as people
find out each and every year I think
they just they got some free agents that
they didn't think they were gonna get or
be a part of is what I've been told but
yeah it's an interesting business and do
you think if they didn't get an Tonio
Brown you'd still be there yes and I
don't think there's necessarily just a
Antonio Brown I think also when I signed
Tyrone Williams and even I think it's
trip around the tackle from the Patriots
I think they were just spending a lot
more money than what they're expecting
to spend and but I'll take the
retirement gift very gracious of them
what if Aaron Rodgers calls you in late
July that'll be an interesting phone
call yeah I don't know that would be I
don't think I could play hypotheticals
but a feature they called and I'm going
to say begging me to come back we're
asking me to come back and they're deed
it it probably would be hard to say no
but we would have to see where we're at
at that point that's the craziest thing
that happened with James Jones a
hereditary rights deal he was in New
York 10 training camp and I tore my ACL
and then everyone he got released by New
York and I was like go get James Jones
he can step right in he knows the system
which it's a little different now since
they have a new coaching you know that's
a new offense but obviously there's a
lot of this thing that's still there
football football so that would be if
that happened that being a very very
interesting question but my guess is
that it won't
Jordy thanks for the moments thanks for
the career and good luck with the rest
of your life and we appreciate your time
I appreciate think that that's a Jordy
Nelson form or Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]